hello welcome to
learning more about notebooks in visual
studio code
my name is tana and i am a program
manager on the vs code team
and today i'll walk you through what
notebooks are
and what they look like in vs code as
well as some custom notebooks that we
have that are exclusive to bs code
so let's get started and the first
question
to ask is what is
a notebook what makes a notebook so
a notebook consists of three types of
items
one is a markdown cell and these are
rich markdown cells that can contain
headers
bullets images whatever you would
normally expect
to be able to be rendered in a markdown
cell
code and this right in this example is
python
but it could be any any other major
language
like javascript java r
julia many other languages and then
finally
output cells that correspond to code
cells and these outputs can be
complex like this data frame here which
is essentially
just a csv view of data
as well as they can be interactive so it
could be a plot
um or it could just be plain text
so just like your system print lines or
your console logs
so notebooks are pretty interesting and
they've definitely become really popular
in recent years but they're actually not
that
new of a concept so notebooks were first
uh coined as literate programming by
donald knuth
from stanford university in 1984. so he
was working
on his thesis on various algorithms and
programs that he was working on and he
wanted to be able to share
his code to someone else and be
completely human readable
he didn't want to have to explain what
was happening and have to guide
a user through what's happening with a
separate piece of documentation
so he wanted all in one document so he
came up with this idea
of having these code macros in inserted
within
rich text so he can explain what's
happening and then
have some code that shows how to do
whatever he's explaining
and then have some possible outputs in
like in relation with that code
and this is how he did his thesis in the
80s
and he actually created a book from the
concept of literature programming
over here that you can see and this is
actually available online if you want to
get it
today so that's what he did first
and then in 1988 will from alpha wolf
from mathematica
came out came around and thought hey you
know
notebook interface is really great and
would be good for our platform
so it works really well with math as
well so you can do
some explanation of what's happening
below in the formula and then you can
have some
code formulas and you can have some
possible outputs for that so this could
be graphs plots
whatever that's related to the math
formula that you have above
so that was in 1988 and then it was a
bit
quiet after that there wasn't too much
going on in the notebook space
until 2015 when the jupiter notebooks
were launched and the jupiter community
was born and
jupiter notebooks have been a huge
success since then especially in the
data science community
where a lot of data scientists use
notebooks to
do various analysis on data
to explain different processes and
explain some machine learning concepts
and
have a really cool form of both playing
around with code
as well as sharing code with others and
sharing concepts with others
so in the last decade it's been really
big and you can
play with jupiter notebooks in many
different platforms including
vs code so what do
jupiter notebooks and other kinds of
notebooks looks like
look like in vs code let's jump into a
demo
so i have vs insiders
and the insider version you always get
the latest up-to-date features that the
vs code team is working on and it's
actually the version that the vs code
team
works on uses to work on vs code daily
so it's what it looks like and i have a
bunch of
example notebooks over here so let's
start with looking at what
jupiter notebooks looks like look like
in vs code they are currently the most
popular kind of notebook
so what does the hello world of jupiter
look like
well we start off with a notebook file
so they end in i pi y and b
so let's create a new one new file and
let's call this
hello hi pynv and so with that vs code
knows it's a notebook you can see that
icon change
and let's hit enter and cool and we're
introduced
with a brand new cell um it's already
set to python
and it will be running python and you
can click here and choose
different types of languages you want to
run i'm just going to run
python of this version for today
and you can add whatever code you'd want
to here so let's start with
print and i actually get all the
intellisense and
everything that i would expect from
normal vs code editors all within the
notebook so
print i see a lot of helpful information
but i'm just going to go ahead and enter
and then i'm going to type in this
string hello world and then i can run
this
it's taking a second to connect and
there we go and so we have a code cell
and an output cell and as you can see we
have options to add more code cells
or more markdown cells so let's look at
what a markdown cell looks like
so when we have empty markdown cell
looks like this we can double click to
edit
and we get the markdown editor that
you're used to in vs code so we can do
hello world
you can even do some bullet points let's
say one
two three
space for that and cool and as you can
see so we get
rich markdown cells here we can do
bullet points you can do images links
whatever you'd expect to do in richmond
cells and we can have
as many code cells as many markdown
cells that we'd like
unlimited opportunities here
and that this is a cool hello world view
of what a jupiter notebook looks like or
notebooks in general looks like
but let's look at what a more realistic
real world view looks like
so i'm going to close this for a second
and open up this
other notebook that i have so this
notebook
is trying to analyze washington state
covet data
so a lot of communities around the world
they are publishing their
covet data for people to analyze use
and you know you can create many models
off of them
to see any trends and so this notebook
we're just doing some exploratory
analysis
on the washington state cover data
that's available to us
so i had the cova data downloaded and i
downloaded and kept it in this folder
with the csv file and i can explain to
whoever
is using my notebook how to get started
so i can explain what package they need
packages they need and packages are the
same as like
npm like node dependencies so you
install them in your machine and then
you can use them
so in this in this cell what it's doing
is it's going through and installing
this pandas package which i'll be using
to read the csv
i already ran this so i don't need to
run this
but i can add as many installations as i
need
and then i can import that library in
that package that i just got
so let's run this it's connected to that
python runtime cool so it looks like we
have
panda successfully imported so let's
actually check so
we are going to now use this library to
read a csv
and then this head function just shows
us the first
five lines of the csv so let's run that
very cool we can see this is from the
csv we see a couple of counties
some day information related to
when the cases started how many cases
and some ages so the age part is
actually pretty cool and
it would be very cool to plot what this
looks like so let's actually try to do
that so let's start with
uh let's remove some of the columns that
we don't need so
we don't need unknown age i don't think
that's a column we need so let's try
removing that
so start covet data and as and this
is available across cells so states it
holds states so let's start with covet
data and let's
try uh dropping
unknown unknown
h with the axis
of and let's run it
okay cool that looks about right all
right
so we dropped unknown age let's also
drop total cases
so notebooks actually hold state so
right now
uh actually i didn't actually set the
variable to be this so let's actually
update this variable
so now it's the original minus
unknown age let's run that again okay
cool
and let's make another cell so we can
actually see what that looks like to
verify
so this once again we'll just return the
first couple so we see that unknown age
is gone
that's great okay and then now let's
update this variable to remove some of
the other
uh column so i also don't want probable
cases
so let's get rid of that one so let's
run this cell
and then let's run this cell great
that's gone
let's also remove confirmed cases
let's turn this cell run this out
great and then let's also remove total
cases
when this cell read this cell okay i
think that should work so i think i
should be able to plot it so let's look
at what that looks like so i have
my covet data that i imported and then i
can just run the plot function on it i
don't have any arguments so let's see
what that looks like
great so this is kind of cool i get to
see
a plot like a histogram of
the frequency of the number of cases
according to their age so that's pretty
cool and so these are some of the
examples of the kind of outputs that you
can get
and you can install many more libraries
and dependencies
to get many more kinds of outputs
and so this is kind of the standard data
science flow that you do
you can even actually inspect so right
now it's not very clear what the state
of this
covid variable is so i can use the
variable explorer
and i can actually see that i have this
code variable and i can actually
open it up in a full screen and
and i get a full like csv view of it so
this is helpful just to make sure
i don't know i'm running a lot of
different cells and different
uh orders so it's hard to tell sometimes
you know what the state of a certain
variable is
so i can use this variable explorer to
just verify
that it's some state that i'd like
so that is a standard data science
example
of using jupyter notebooks to clean
analyze and view some data but what does
uh jupiter notebooks look like from a
playground rupple example
so i have this other notebook here which
is a typescript notebook so
as you can see it's using typescript as
its runtime and has the language of
typescript selected
and i'm using this notebook to play
around with this express server that i
have
and specifically also to play around the
axios
library because i don't 100 know you
know
how it works and i want to make sure
that it works in the way that i expect
before i'm adding it into my code base
so let's start by running this server so
i'm going to go into the package.json
and i'm going to hit run script over
here
cool that it looks like it's running so
let's go back into our notebook
and i already uh npm installed axios so
i can just run this
this will start typescript and start
this base request instance and now i can
use that request instance across
many different cells so i can start off
with just running the basics
to get the home page which is just the
default express home page at the moment
i also created an endpoint called api
so i can call that and i can see oh very
cool i can grab that
i can copy and paste this cell and
change this to okay i want to actually
grab users
so let me type this users instead
run that cool i get three names
and i can use this to play around with
axios get it to how i like
play around with how my express server
is reacting to
different calls and you know
work on my code at the same time and so
this is pretty helpful
when you're working on both the back end
and the front end but you don't really
want to go in and set up this large
project
or inject all of this into a project
that you already have so you can
take a notebook and work on it
independently in an isolated space and
then when you're happy
like oh yeah i'm kind of happy with how
this access work is
working then i might copy and paste over
the code into
my client-side app so
this is helpful and it was cool to use
but you know
it's a lot of code and sometimes i'm
only working on my express server
and i'm not really working on the client
side
so i want to create a notebook that will
help me just do
rest calls and not deal with any of the
code that's associated with it
but i want to do this all from vs code
because i want to be as close to me
developing my server
so i at the beginning of working on the
vs code team
decided to be very cool to create a
notebook
that will run rest calls and so this is
a custom notebook which
is why it doesn't have the ipynb ending
it's not part of
the jupyter ecosystem but it's instead a
special notebook
that can only be run on vs code and so
let's look at what that looks like so it
has the name restbook
and if i click into it i see
that i don't have it running or now so
let's start running it so i
have the same markdown cells but i have
a special a special
rest book language and this language
uh introduces all these the syntax
highlighting and such so let's start by
running one and see what it looks like
so let's run
the basics cool so i get this cool view
which is different from the other
uh this view over here
it looks a bit nicer in my opinion and i
can go through the different areas of
information i can see what i
sent i can see the headers that i get
back and i can see the data
i can even switch to a different kind of
output so there's a built-in
html view and i can actually see what
that looks like so yeah that looks like
the html that i expect from my express
app
i can go back to this view i can make
sure that certain things exist
so let's say i want to make sure that
express exists
i can enter search and i can see okay
yeah cool this is exactly what i expect
and like other notebooks i can keep
running in other cells
so this one it doesn't show that much
state across cells
it's a lot of just querying so i can
grab users then i can grab
all the users and then i can grab the
information
for a specific user
and that's all very cool but
you know when i was working on this
notebook and when i gave previous
presentations
someone gave a really cool feature
request idea of
actually utilizing the state part of
notebooks and actually
using the information from one notebook
in another
so to do that i implemented that in my
custom language
where i can declare something to belong
to a certain
variable so let's say let's foo equals
this
now when i run it foo has the value of
the return
from this call so now i can actually use
foo over here instead of the hardcore
name sana
so i can do dollar sign foo
and let's grab from the data that we got
back
and it was the first item and now if i
run it
i get the same call again with senna and
i can get all of her information and now
i can
you know dynamically choose the second
user and
so on and so on so that's helpful
if i just want to have almost like a
test class
in my notebook where this is kind of my
testing but not an official
testing suite but just a side testing
suite which i use to just
mess around with my server and make sure
that it works in the way i expect
and i can also do
sorry i have a lot of little gnats in my
house um
i can also do post requests so i can
send to my server
hello world i can see that my server
says it's received this
and that looks good and then this is all
useful
but what's even more useful is to also
have api
keys because we don't always want to be
saving
our sensitive information just purely in
data like this
so the other very cool part about doing
custom notebooks and using vs code apis
to make notebooks is that you also get
access to
all of the other apis that vs code
already supports so i get
access to all the language apis and
that's what i can use to make a very
rich language so if
i can get auto completions like this
user agent and i can say
you know the user agent is me for
example
and i can get like all the syntax
highlighting everything
that you would expect from language apis
but i can also get access to the secrets
api
which is an api that allows you to save
sensitive information
to your vs code that's not available
that you can use
later in your various extensions so what
does that actually look like so let's
start
with i have this command called secret
so command shift p
you open up the command palette and you
can search for rest book secrets
so enter that and let's add a new secret
so let's call it my secret
secret key cool
and then let's make my secret key be
openjs is the value all right so looks
like we successfully saved that
all right i took a quick pause to deal
with this fly that was bothering me
but alright so we have our secret saved
so let's look at how to use it so we can
add a code cell
and let's start another request
localhost
and let me just check yes so i have
this endpoint called secret so let's use
this i'll just copy
this over and we can use that
and then and then i can actually access
my secrets like this so i can do secrets
and then dot my secret key and if i send
it i can see that
i respond with i have a secret and if i
look at the actual logs
of my server i see that i've actually
received that same secret that says
openjs
and if i look at the information about
the request i sent
i actually hide the secret so this is
super useful for if you want to share
this notebook with others but you don't
want to send them the sensitive
information all the sensitive
information is hidden
but you can still use it to make those
calls and
the cool useful part of this is you
could have your co-worker
or your friend have a secret or the api
key
saved in their secrets as hopefully the
same name
and then they can run the notebook and
get the exact same result but you're not
ever risking the risk of actually
sharing your secret api keys anywhere
and just to make sure this worked let's
try changing this api key so let's go
back to our secrets
and we see this my secret api key let's
view the secret and let's just change it
so let's call it
hello instead enter and so now i see
that i've saved it and let's run it one
more time
all right so from this view it looks the
exact same
because for the encryption part you
don't
really see anything but as you can see
that i have a different response so i
can use
as many api keys as i want i can save as
many secrets i can change them as i need
and that's super helpful for actually
doing rest calls
so this is one example of a custom
notebook that's
solely nvs code that's using the vs code
apis
to create the notebook and as well as
integrate with the rest of the
extensibility and functionality that vs
code offers
extensions we have another example and
i'll close these for now
we have another example called the
github issues notebook
so the github issues notebook started
from a need from our team
that where we live on github all of our
issues are there our roadmap is there
iteration plans are there literally
everything is on github
including all of our bugs and we get
several hundreds of bugs every day
we get a lot a lot of bugs i think if
you look on the repo now there's
probably about 5 000 issues
there's a lot going on all the time and
it's
pretty annoying to have to open up a
browser every single
time and go on to the repo and then
search for the
specific kind of like issues that you
want like specific labels and such and
you have to do this for each individual
repo
and also the vs code team a lot of our
work is spread across
several different repos because we like
to separate the work out into smaller
extensions
so a lot of times people on the vs co
team are managing multiple sections all
at the same time
and so it's extra annoying to have to
open up different repos and check
different repos
for the same same values of this is
i'm the author and these are bugs
assigned to me or open to me or whatever
so to help us with that experience we
made the github issues notebook and so
this helps us
triage and work through all those github
issues all within vs code all within one
notebook
so it follows the same github language
where we have things like
repo and we have is open assignee et
cetera
but we also added a couple extra things
variables
uh so dollar sign repo referring to this
is now a variable
of repo there's another variable of who
i am
which is my my github handle tanaka beer
so if i run it it actually ends up
running all of our notebook cells
and you can see that it's going for this
one it's
going through these three different
repos all at once so the vs code repo
the github pull request extension and
the remote extension
and looking for all the issues that i've
created
and so this is really helpful to see
everything in one view and i can even
open all these issues
and if i click this button it will open
14
tabs all each with each individual issue
so that's
a really easy way to just go through all
of your issues um
let's look at specifically our my
uh repo that i want to see so all the
open issues where i'm assigned to in my
repo so i see these so i need to add
these three features
to my rest book and we actually use this
extension
on the vs code team so if you clone vs
code which i have right here if you
clone vs code you'll you'll see this
folder notebooks
and we have a bunch of different uh
notebooks that we use to
go through all the different issues we
have uh end game related things which
are when we're releasing we have some
extra issues and work that we have to do
around we keep
track of paper cuts here we keep track
of everything and
this is what our team uses and we add a
lot of information about how to do
the different roles if you're on inbox
tracking which really means
just going through all the open issues
on our repo for that week
you get a lot of information on how to
do that and then you also get
already sorry you get code cells that
show you what to run
to get all that information and we use
this heavily in the vs code team
to iterate through all of our issues so
that's a second example of a custom
notebook that is useful in the vs
code and we have one more example
so the last example is we have a cousin
notebook
so kusto is a language that we use
in our team to create through all of our
data
it's an open language and we use kudzu
to just go through
all the telemetry data that we have so
puso offers some
playground data so these are store
events and this
notebook is connecting to that cousteau
cluster and you can use the custo
language
so i can run this and i get the outputs
of what they would look like in cousteau
a couple bugs here and there with the
rendering
but this is pretty much exactly what it
looks like in custo
and so i can do some more fancy stuff so
cousteau allows us to do some
graphing so i can put all this data on a
chart so i can see
by state which ones are the more popular
states for storms
so running this i see okay texas is
pretty popular and these are
quite these are also like interactive
charts as you can see when i hover over
i get some exact numbers
so i see that texas is quite popular and
then kansas is second popular
and you know that was cool but i want to
see a pie chart version so i can run the
same query but just finish it off with a
pie chart
and then i i get an interactive pie
chart like this and so
in this notebook it's a really quick and
easy way to play around with the data
that we have
and see what what we get and then we i
can share this notebook with my
co-workers
to see you know oh hey look at this
pie chart of data so yeah this is
one other way of interacting and
normally we would use
azure data azure data explorer which is
a website where we run custom queries on
but this is all within vs code all in
one spot and i can run multiple queries
on the same page and then send someone
hey this is my analysis this is what i
see so this is
like data science but it's not using any
standard
language it's using cousteau language
which is a specialized language
within microsoft so these
are some custom notebooks i'm going back
to
my powerpoint so at first i showed you
jupiter notebooks
uh and that is a standard experience
outside of vs code and within vs code
except vs code has a couple extra
extensive features um but then i also
showed you custom
custom notebooks not jupiter custom
notebooks
and these are notebooks that are made
especially for vs code that's using vs
code apis
to create the notebook and it only works
within vs code
and so this was the rest book this was
the github issues notebook and this was
also the kusto notebook
and the cool part is anyone can make a
custom notebook
we have our api open you can use it
today you can make your custom notebook
to do whatever you'd like
and you get the full engineering support
from us so you'll get all the security
and performance from us
the notebooks will have access to all
the key bindings the editors have access
to the themes
you get everything that you would expect
from normal editor but you can
make your own notebook you can use a
rich api that already exists for other
parts like i showed you with the
language api you can use
you can use the secrets api you can use
all of the other apis that vs code
offers for extensions
and you can be discoverable through the
marketplace
and this is really exciting because
we're excited to see what kind of
domains
come out of this come out of notebooks
these we just showed you a couple but
we're very excited very
excited to see what you guys will come
up with with
this api and what kind of cool notebooks
that are outside of experiences that we
already have today
so thank you for attending this talk and
getting a deep dive into notebooks
some next steps you can do to explore
notebooks further one is you can
install insiders so that that way you
get the latest experience
with notebooks and any other features
that vs code is working on
and if you want to create your own
notebook i did a live stream
two months ago on vs code about how to
actually create a notebook
and i did i coded up a notebook within
the live stream so you can see how easy
it is to do it it takes about 30 minutes
in that live stream
and it's really easy to get started so
there's a link um
that you'll you'll have access to for
this youtube link
but yeah and thank you so much for
joining uh hopefully you get creative
and i'm we're very excited to see what
kind of notebooks show up in the
marketplace from you guys
thank you guys see ya